I think you'd prefer to win because
we're great listeners we care we're
great listeners
I think extroverts are usually the worst
to give an advice it's don't spend
enough time listening it's easy to look
at Kevin O'Leary and these guys on TV is
the loudmouth ways to win because
they're betting on what they're good at
all the introvert entrepreneurs you
don't hear about them because they're
introverts that's not how they work but
there's tons of people who build giant
companies we're on the list of the
richest people in the world who've never
heard of as they went on being a gerbil
so being an introvert yeah how do you
feel that calms you or helps you and
being an entrepreneur because that's
something that I think I can relate to
you on as being introverted and we
listen training energy being around
people for too long we listen it's also
like the right people like being around
you guys brings me up yeah I gain more
energy with the day you guys have some
breaks happen to have no breaks so like
we're going all the way through this
brings me up I'll go home and crash I'm
on three hours sleep I haven't eaten
anything I have four bars sitting next
we have eaten zero just had coffee and
it's 3:30 but I'll go home and like die
tonight right Nina
but I don't feel it like I could stay
here for a long time so when you find it
but in most other situations I'm
massively introverted so you can find it
if you're in your element you can find
it and because connection is important
to you being with people will be
important just you have to find the
right create the right environment
scenarios for yourself and then I think
it converts a win because we're great
listeners we care we're great listeners
I think X of us are usually the worst to
give an advice they don't spend enough
time listening
you're not thinking about the other
person you just thinking about
themselves you gotta go do this this is
what I'd a day how you saw well like I'm
not a sales guy no I'm not I don't want
it
right so I think that's how you win and
it's easy to look at Kevin O'Leary and
these guys on TV is the loudmouth ways
to win cuz they're betting on what
they're good at all the introvert
entrepreneurs you don't hear about them
because they're introverts that's not
how they went but there's tons of people
who've built giant companies who are on
the list of the richest people in the
world who've never heard of because they
win on being ancient you challenged me
to Rick really get started on one for
all yeah and that meant the world to me
yeah and I could already feel the growth
just from that yeah and you're
challenging people all around what do
you think is the importance of
presenting challenges to people and how
do you approach that challenging mindset
if that makes sense
I think if you want to be a leader you
have to care more about the people
winning than you winning with the people
mm-hmm so I badly want you to win
irregardless of me like if I never see
you again if I'm never here for one for
all again if has never everything to do
with my business like I want you to win
I want this thing to take off I want you
to spark your movement it's just a deep
sense of really wanting the people that
are around me to win and so whether I'm
with you for 20 minutes doing an
interview or whether I'm with you for a
long time because you're on my team I
want you to I want you to win I want you
to grow that's like one of my greatest
fears is letting people down and that
causes me a lot of pain what's the whole
thing I have to challenge you because
otherwise I know I'm letting you down I
have to push you because if I don't I
know I'm capable of helping you and I
haven't see responsibility yeah I'm
letting you down and myself if you see
somebody crying and you know that just
smiling then we're giving a hug we'll
help them and you don't that's your
fault the thing that's still for me it's
still never enough but I still use it as
a it's a it's a positive I see as a
positive not a negative
the fact that you didn't push back hard
enough on the challenges is not a
reflection of you but of me is how I
interpret it like you did it which is
great but it wasn't that hard to get you
to do it which means I could have pushed
you harder on something else because I
don't want to celebrate just moving
forward I want to celebrate like I
wanted to go as far as possible so we
traveled a great distance but I could
have taken you even further so as much
as you feel like you've grown a lot and
took that thing that took eight months
and made it happen ASAP which is awesome
I'm still thinking Dane could have been
like 18 times better too if I was better
I struggled to feel comfortable like I
want to challenge people but it's it's
almost like it's very hard because I
almost feel hesitant to want to push
people too too hard but so if you don't
if you're not pushing too hard you don't
know what the limit is yeah and you have
to be able to push them with something
that they want you wanted to go give the
nachos to that guy but if you wanted to
go and do that yeah so you have to go do
that but me pushing somebody else like
yeah okay again it's a good D but like
okay it's just not it's not a big deal
for them so the the worst advice you
give is under what you would do in their
situation and you can't push people on
that
well how do you do cuz it seems like
ain't quad of us are we get motivated by
challenges like when what other
challenges are like for your best
interest
right diem Cyrus Webb go on his radio
show he wants to hear from there's no
excuse for anybody here who wants to be
a thought leader not to go on a radio
show it's just fear so do it
but something else they may not it's not
housing them about point
so you have to understand what it is
that they want and push them hard to go
after what they want how I handle the
situation that's why a lot of times at
the time I'm saying like maybe I'm the
weirdo like I'm the I'm the weird duck
or the weird bird this is how I do it
because I can't impose that on you and
may not be the best way for you to
handle that situation if we sit down
when I want I can I I will channel you
when we're doing our videos I'm trying
to channel what you would say I'm trying
to vibe vibed and cons we pull some
words that to take your message and use
my communication skill to bring it out
so you have a quality video in a short
amount of time but I can't tell you what
I would do in your situation and then
impose it on you sure that's that's what
most people do when they challenge
people this is what I did this is what I
would do so you should go do it too
maybe that's the worst advice of all
time like your parents if they say well
I want to work at a company for 40 years
in them retired you should do that too
Dan don't you want to be happy don't you
want to make money don't you want to be
stable but they spent no time actually
trying to understand what it is that you
want so that's that's the thing that I'm
constantly trying to try to keep in mind
that's the building to the 85 percent
this is something that I would do is
this just something how I would react to
it or is this actually the best thing
for them so we're talking about having a
powerful opinion you need to have a
powerful opinion I don't get I don't
have to agree with your opinion I could
be totally against what you are saying
like guns are amazing I want and I want
to you know shoot squirrels all day long
awesome okay tell me why like I work
with you you believe that great
why are shooting squirrels like the
greatest thing of all time give me I
want to go deeper with it to help you
craft your argument because it's the
best thing for you so where most people
fail is they challenge people off of
something of how they would react no
I've actually give them the best advice
for that person
so that's the thing to check yourself on
I want to challenge this person but do
they actually want to grow are they
ready to grow do they actually want that
thing and most of the time we're just
seeing it through our lens instead of
theirs
all I do is hold up a mirror I just make
the mirror like I take the fog away
that's it this is your your life your
goals is where you're saying tell me
that that makes sense you're like okay
it doesn't make sense
right right so that's why I would just
constantly if you want to get better at
that game just constantly adjusting like
this this is what I would do or just
what they should do and that takes like
deeply understanding the person you're
dealing with yeah in pattern recognition
yeah seeing doing it enough times right
if you do it a lot of times you'll see
the similar things coming up and then
you know you're making the judgment you
get to 85 percent I've seen it enough so
you're making a judgment call boom like
that's your job as a leader to take the
thing that somebody's been sitting on
for eight months and make it happen
right now I just make it seem simple it
may be a difficult thing to do because
of fear but the actual act is not that
difficult to jump out of a plane is not
is a simple move you know it takes a lot
of guts but it's a simple act to go and
fill a plate full of nachos and go give
it to a homeless guy it's easy anybody
can do it it's not it's not it's a
simple move but it's difficult and just
a judgment like like I have to do it now
right look when are you gonna do it
you're gonna wait another eight months
yeah another eight months like you're
gonna wait 2:38 before you right and so
I put the pressure myself that I know I
can help if you don't know how if you
don't know what they need to do even
just supporting them even just listen to
them even just smiling with them hugging
them if somebody's crying like you may
not know how to help but just a hug is
help just listening just caring is value
but if you know what they need to do
because you've listened or you've been
through it yourself and you know this is
the next step it's gonna serve them then
you have to push them to do it that's my
like I have to I have to get you to do
it
because you you need to do it and if you
don't it's my fault if you didn't go
give that homeless guy nachos like I
wouldn't sleep that night it affects me
personally deeply like you have to do it
or I'm not going to sleep because I let
you down right and they'll let myself
down like I'm getting emotional talking
about it
like that's how how deep its rooting in
me right and then even the thing that
you challenged me to go do an act of
kindness to somebody that's me it's not
a huge deal you know but okay great like
challenge awesome and then I take my
security guard and hey I'm on like I
want to say I love you and yokes got a
big smile on your face and you do such a
great job
boom fist bumping you know what's going
to have it he feels good and then he
wants to challenge somebody else it's a
simple act for me it's not difficult
let's just remembering but I know that
that would mean something to you that
you challenged me that I followed
through on it that that would give you
more confidence in what you're doing so
I have to do it thank you for that come
in thank you for everything Evan very
appreciated let's go
raise your standard Apple at the core
it's core value that passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's something serene this interview was
done as a part of my Toronto workshop if
you want more details on the next one to
sign up check out the link right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there